Henry Ford was the leading manufacturer of American automobiles in the early 1900s.
He revolutionized the young automobile industry...
...by developing the assembly line method of production.
By manufacturing his own parts...
...and developing a huge system of conveyors to bring the parts to the assembly line,...
...Ford reduced the cost of manufacturing automobiles.
And Ford passed on much of the savings created by the assembly line production to his customers.
In 1908, when the Ford Motor Company introduced the Model T,...
...it cost $850.
By 1924, assembly line innovations helped reduce the price of a Model T to $290...
...and automobile was now within reach of the average family.